the scientists at japan's primate
research institute the pri where ayumu
is based have devised intelligence tests
for chimps
one test is for what's called working
memory the brain's ability to
temporarily store and use information
the numbers one to nine are randomly
scattered across a touch screen
the chimp looks at them for as long as
is needed to memorize the layout
then as soon as one is touched the other
numbers are hidden and must now be
remembered
we volunteered chris the director of
this program to demonstrate this test
he's a college graduate and a crossword
addict but how good is his working
memory
when chris reckons he has memorized the
layout he touches one when the others
are hidden he must try to recall two to
nine in ascending order
it takes me ages to remember where
they're all placed and then i think i've
got it
it's really very very difficult
in 30 attempts chris only once reached
nine without making a mistake
as soon as they're blanked over
it's like my mind's been blanked over as
well
when are you moose at the same test he
correctly remembered the numbers almost
90 percent of the time
ayuma gets it right
almost every time
and i've got it right once
chris fears he's let his species down
but even when the pri played a yumu
against their best human students who
were given regular practice sessions
ayumu still beat all humans
other chimps at the pri have also sat
the exams
among these apes computer skills are as
normal as the ability to swing from the
trees
though none of his rivals beat a yumu a
few came close
and average chip results turned out to
be higher than amongst humans
so does that efficient working memory
mean chimps are cleverer than humans
we track down a scientist who studies
chimps in the wild
dr nick newton fisher i think it's
interesting the results that suggest
that chimps may have particular
cognitive abilities that are different
and maybe in some aspects better than
humans because chimpanzees are not small
primitive furry humans they are a
species that we share a common ancestor
with maybe five or six million years ago
but they've evolved along their own
individual path are they better at doing
chimp things and we're better at doing
human things
and something some chimp things may not
simply be climbing up and down trees and
eating figs some of those chimp things
might be mental abilities as well
that's chimps one humans nil
you